jessica's in bristol virginia hi
jessica how are you i'm great thank you
so much for taking my call
sure what's up um i was just
i mean i found you guys probably about a
month ago and i'm just trying to figure
out
i'm a special education teacher um and
then i have a five-year-old daughter who
has autism
so like there's not an option for me to
go out and work
a second or a third job because my
parents who takes care of
your parents take care of her while
you're at school yes i live with my
parents i'm purchasing
our family home from them in a private
sale like i pay them
so much per month don't really pay them
i paid certain bills
um and um so
they but my daughter needs me to be home
so there's not an option for me to go
out and get
additional work and i already work 35
minutes
um one way for my house i'm traveling
about an hour a day
sorry in transportation how long you've
been doing
how long you've been doing special ed um
i started out as an agent i was making
about 15 000
a year and then how long have you been
doing this
i'm sorry i've been doing special ed as
a teacher for
four years now this is my fourth year
okay and you're raising
a child with autism yes
so this makes you what's known as an
expert
in the field of special education
yes you have experience you have
experience and you're a parent
i would come to you if i needed some
some questions answered
on special education because i think
you're a credible source
and this is your this is your extra
money
and it's all online you develop an
online presence
and you start coaching people and build
support groups
for people that have the same fears and
hurts and broken hearts that you have
you understand it like no other
and you can give advice and coaching and
uh you can build a following of people
that'll do that and
they will pay you for that it may take a
little while and you have to develop a
little bit of an entrepreneurial
business model
but that's one thing that pops into my
head the other thing that pops into my
head is
while you're watching your child at home
it would not be convenient but for a
short term in order to
make some more money to clean up some of
your other stuff you could watch another
child
that had special needs of some kind that
allowed you to do both your child
and that child it couldn't be
overwhelming is my point but you could
do that okay
if i was to watch watch somebody else's
child in my own home wouldn't i need
some sort of
insurance to protect um no it's just
called tutoring
if you're just tutoring you're going to
start you're going to start
tutoring high functioning autism
students
and you're going to tutor them to
increase the skill of
math or reading or whatever it is that
the parent is concerned about
because you know how to do that and you
can do that for an hour a day at home
twice a week and you could make fifty
dollars during that hour
an extra two hundred dollars a week an
extra eight hundred dollars
a month and that's a lot of money in
your world
yeah it is yeah and i made all of that
up just now by the way i have no idea if
that's right
but my point is you're not going to go
out and work the quote extra job
because there's no one to watch your
child your parents have already been
doing it all day
and you need some time with them they
need you
the extra money jessica what are you
your question calling in
is it do you need extra money are you
looking for ways to earn it
what's the what's your what's your main
question
um i'm pretty foreign debt as far as
student loans credit cards know the
house payment isn't that big a deal
um how much debt how much debt do you
have
um i have about 120
000 in debt roughly okay
so you're overwhelmed i mean what kind
of debt is this
um the majority of it is a student loan
debt because
um i was working as an aide before
working as a teacher
and i couldn't live on being an aide i
couldn't cash for my education being an
aide but i had to
do something in the field that i love
and so i went from making 15 000 a year
to making 36 000
a year which sounds amazing when you
think about it like that but
it doesn't take care of it when you have
almost a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt
yeah yeah okay
yeah i think you've got to develop a
side gig
that allows you to be with your child
and also allows you to create some
income and those are the two ideas that
popped into my head
they're not magical and they're not easy
and they're not instantaneous
you could do both of them but i mean you
work on online stuff when your kids
sleep at night but you've you're right
it's going to take
too long at 36 000 to address a hundred
thousand dollar student loan debt
and even if there's a family jessica and
again all of these are short-term
solutions like we don't want you to live
like this for the rest of your life i
mean this is
for the short term maybe a year two
years
whatever it is but even if there's a
family near the school one of your
students that you have in class
that lives near the school so you're
already driving out there
maybe you go an hour earlier 45 minutes
earlier
do some one-on-one tutoring at their
home before you go in to work or
things like that but again it's thinking
outside the box something that again
doesn't take you away
too long from your child because i hear
i hear you and as a working mom by the
end of the day you're ready just to be
with your kids
um but it is having to think outside the
box
for a short period of time you're not
outside the box like you're going to go
in this whole separate area my point is
you are an expert
utilize that in some way to give you the
lift
and you you you know as long as you have
the emotional capacity
to spend that much more time with uh
special needs folks then if you've got
that then i
i would highly recommend that you're
doing this and you're somehow coaching
the moms and dads along
it's just a it's a as you know it's a
great community of people
that gather together on this and so
there's word will get out
that you have the answers and uh you
know
and that you had you know when when you
get with miss jessica things happen you
know i mean that's
that's that's what you want people
saying about you